[music]
Emily: "Hey, guys!
This is Emily Conover, physics reporter for Science News,
coming at you from a tent.
We're here in Corvallis
on a converted athletic field of some sort.
And marveling at how blue the sky is,
so we hope it stays that way for the next few hours,
so that we can get a great view of the eclipse."
Emily: "Ok, check it out guys, I'm gonna look."
"Ahh! It's so cool."
[screams of joy and wonder]
Emily: "Oh my god, it's amazing!"
Emily: "The sun is back!"
[cheering]
[music]
Laura: "That was wild!"
Lisa: "Hi! I'm Lisa Grossman!
I'm the astronomy writer at Science News.
I'm with Alyssa Boll.
Introduce yourself."
Alyssa: "Hello, I'm Alyssa Boll,
and I'm an intern with the
High Altitude Observatory this summer.
And we have three experiments
going on for the eclipse."
[music]
Erika: "Hi, this is Erika Engelhaupt,
writer and former editor at Science News magazine.
I'm enjoying the eclipse
from beautiful Madisonville, Tennessee,
in the foothills of the Smoky Mountains."
Gordon: "So we have one minute to see
the shadow race toward those mountains,
go over the mountains,
and go through the clouds.
[cheers]
Erika: "It's gone! Woo!"
[music]
Erika: "Oh my god! We're standing in the dark."
Helen: "Ok, so it's the morning of the day of the eclipse.
And the weather's looking good.
We've got about two or three hours to go.
So, fingers crossed."
[music]
[hooting and hollering]
[crickets chirping]
[music]
"Happy eclipse from Columbia, South Carolina!"
[cheering]
[music]